listen man
um you know I've been a fan of your work
for a while but there's a lot of people
that actually haven't seen anything
you've done so if someone has never seen
anything that you've been in what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
oh God that's a great question such a
revealing question
um I mean I do think that
first season of stranger things
uh is probably
thing where you'll get to know me the
best and kind of what I do and I think
it's probably
the most impressive sort of subtle thing
I've done uh the Arc of that character
and sort of How It's especially in that
first season
it's the work that I think I'm proudest
of at this point uh you've done a lot of
different things which shot or sequence
ended up being the the toughest thing
that you've done in your career in a
movie
uh toughest how
um you know maybe it'd be either because
of the performance or because of the
camera move or because you know what I
mean the technical aspects of the shot
there was
a lot of really tough big stuff on Black
Widow
that we shot like a lot of because a lot
of that prison stuff was kind of insane
a lot of movement like 500 backgrounds
um a lot of difficult angles and Camera
moves and stuff like that
um another one that really does jump out
though is same thing at the end of that
first season of stranger things
when we were in the library at the end
of the at the end of the show where we
pull will out of the vines and we do the
CPR on him that was particularly
difficult
because of all the technical elements of
doing CPR
I'm that kid the spores in the air the
suits we were wearing
Reflections things like that and it was
a night shoot I was a really tough day
as well so
um I would say like of the things a lot
of that prison stuff in Black Widow was
really hard and then that last day of
stranger things season one was really
hard as well they say that every New
York City actor will eventually be on
Law and Order you have done I believe
four episodes of Law and Order each of
course a different one
um which was your favorite character to
play I think I've done even more than
that I think I've done
I think I've done six
because my prep work was terrible and
now I want to lay it down I'm gonna lay
it down for you I did my first one was
like a one day roll on Law and Order
it was I played a waiter at a restaurant
where the cops come and interview you
about the suspect so I had three lines
Mike the waiter and it was when Jerry
Orbach was still doing the show and I
remember he had a scene with me and it
was my first
big thing I had done soap operas before
but I was a I was a waiter on the show
and it was a big deal and I remember
showing up
I remember showing up and seeing all
this background like they had like you
know 50 people in the bar and they were
smoking up the bar and I just couldn't
believe that they were gonna put the
camera on me like with all these people
and I just could not believe it I was so
excited and nervous and I remember
trying to get my coverage before lunch
and I was so nervous they put the camera
set up and Jerry Orbach was right off
camera and he just like leaned in and he
touched my hand he said you got this
and that and it was so wonderful for an
old New York guy to do that to me guy
I've been there
felt so gratifying that whole thing
um but I did two regular law orders two
criminal intents and two uh SUVs uh
Special Victims because every two years
in New York you can go back and play
another villain uh that was kind of the
rule in New York but I remember there
was uh I guess the one I liked the most
was um
I think it was written by Renee uh
Bowker I think is his name but he was it
was Criminal Intent
and it was uh it was about a guy who
a guy who like loses it
kind of has a psychotic episode and
believes that he's the savior of the
world or something and it was a bit it
was based on people were receiving pipe
bombs at Banks and stuff like that so he
builds a pipe bomb sends it to a bank
but he also like kills his daughter's
dance teacher like kills his his uncle
or killed all these people and then
winds up taking his daughter out to the
woods and saying that she is the second
coming and they're gonna like be
together and save the world it's like
really creepy dude and I loved it it was
me and Vincent
um at the end who had something called
the Arya a nutshell which was like he he
and the murderer get together for about
like 10 pages and he just like figures
out a way to manipulate them into
confessing
and and that was just really fun it was
a really creepy guy and Vincent and I
had a big old 10-page Aria and I had
known Vincent before that and we had
just a great time doing that Arya so
that was probably my favorite one uh
jumping into why I get to talk to you
today I'm going to start with
congratulations
um talk a little bit about this project
and were you and just getting involved
was this something that when they
approached you about this were you like
wait me Santa Claus and he's really
Santa Claus and I'm gonna be kicking ass
wait what
yeah basically you're doing the exact
impression of me it was it was a little
darker than that though it was more like
what like I don't get it past I think it
was the first response and they were
like no no wait a minute wait a minute I
was like no no what are you talking
about a violent Santa Claus movie he's
like he's kicking asking him it doesn't
make any sense to me he said let talk to
the director and talk to David Leach to
produce her and I'd known David a little
bit and um
they called me up and
I hadn't even read the script they just
wanted they wanted to talk to me before
the before they sent me the script and
Tommy where Cola is this weird like
Norwegian I keep calling weird I'm
worried he's gonna see one of these
interviews maybe nice to meet it was
kind of try he's got a childlike
and sweet and he like loves Christmas he
loves reindeer because they eat them up
in Norway they do all kinds of stuff
with reindeer but he loves the whole
Christmas thing and leech is a big
action guide I've always admired those
like Atomic blonde and nobody the ones
where the actor gets to do most of the
choreography
and I'd always want to do one of those
so they pitched me this thing that they
said was wild and they said it was a big
swing but if we could pull it off it
would be really cool and and they sent
me the script
and it did feel like a big swing it felt
like
you have an action movie but in the
middle of it you obviously have a comedy
but in the real true center of it you
have a Christmas movie like
you know the best Hallmark Christmas
movie or or in my mind the the top shelf
which is Miracle on 34th Street which is
just like
is he real is Santa real like a little
girl going through some problems who
needs to believe in something in her
life and she finds Santa Claus
he's real and Christmas is about giving
and love and and
all these things
and I thought that was really stressful
really unique when I read it in the
script it it made me tear up at the end
and I thought wow that's special because
a lot of scripts it's hard enough to get
through them this one I got through and
at the end in those scenes with him and
her where he's saying you know I better
get going now it's
it made me tear up and I was like oh
this could be really special if we get
it right but I still at that time
thought it was a big swing and it was
gonna be
real hard we had to go go to work real
hard on it and we did and uh but that
was what made me want to do it that it
was so unique
and uh even though it was a big action
movie I got like emotional at the end of
it action scenes look amazing when
you're watching them at home in the
comfort of your couch or in a movie
theater but filming them is a holy [ __ ]
pain in the ass
um at what point in the shoot were you
like why did I sign on for this movie
like before the shoot even began I was
that way I went up to Winnipeg
with the stunt guys for a month before
even pre-production we had a month of
training in winnebag and then we went
home for Christmas and then we came back
in January had another month of prep to
train
but for that month in December I was
already eating because I wanted him to
be big so I was eating a lot and I
showed up at these training rehearsals
with these guys we were doing wrestling
mainly Jiu Jitsu and wrestling and I
don't know if you've ever wrestled I
never had I do this thing called
pummeling and wrestling it's basically
just like grabbing a guy and he grabs
you and you just do this for hours
and it is the most tiring and exhausting
thing I have ever I've never been that
tired in my life we train for about
three or four hours a day
and then I would just go pass out and
sleep like 16 hours and wake up in the
morning and do it again
it was so exhausting and these guys are
so uh skilled and they also make you
look so good because they're doing the
reactions so you're just trying to keep
up with their choreography
um
but they also were so sweet but they had
endless energy
and I was just exhausted
um
but it you know
being able at this age to have be paid
to learn new disciplines and learn new
things in life is such a gift and when
you're working with skilled
professionals like that it's something
that I wouldn't want to miss so I you
know I kept showing up and I kept
showing up on time it was exhausting but
it was also it's just real gratifying to
be able to learn something like that
uh at the stage in life so it was it was
also very rewarding did you get to keep
skull crusher no I don't have a skull
graduate but I have uh his stand-in
who's the like Sledgehammer from the
shed I have I have a I have one of those
yeah what I appreciate it is listen uh
there's been a lot of great Christmas
movies and this one nods Home Alone nods
Die Hard uh can you sort of talk about
that aspect that it you know it's having
fun yeah absolutely I mean there's so
many throughout the movie there's so
many homages
to all these Christmas movies and that
was what really stuck out for me not
even so much the Home Alone we actually
talk about home alone in the movie the
little girl had just watched home alone
and then later on the movie there's a
sequence that's very home alone with the
bad guys
um which is great it's a it's a great
sequence it's hilarious that's that that
sequence is a plus yeah people love that
secret it's a terrific sequence
um
and yeah when I read the movie it was
really die hard that stuck out to me
and you know
there's even sequences where uh
he doesn't necessarily say the exact
lines but there's a lot of McLean has a
lot of one-liners in that movie where
it's like come to New York like it'll be
great they said like and I think uh or
ho ho ho you know I have a machine gun
would you write
but there's a lot of that in the movie
as well it's kind of got a throwback
feel
to even some of the old Schwarzenegger
movies like Commando there's a lot of
there was a lot of one-liners which
we've in the edit have massaged because
we felt like we didn't quite need them
but the script itself has a real 80s
feel to it at its at its bones you know
Santa was running around saying like
these guys are Feliz Navidad or I'm
gonna eat these guys like a plate full
of cookies they like one liners that
you'd find in an old Schwarzenegger
movie
um there's something about that that I
like because you know
um
we I we started to they've experimented
with it in stranger things certainly as
well
where there's a lot of these old tropes
where the genre itself
the popular movie genre had a real peak
in it
in the 80s with these particular movies
or like
uh and I
I think there's some going back to that
looking back at how great that was that
we as audiences want we want that
Spielberg flavor again or we want that
die hard flavor again
and so
I thought it was really fun in the
script that they paid a lot of almost
movies and those movies are just
spectacular movies
um so yeah we have a lot of Die Hard
homage we have a lot of Home Alone
homage but but we're yeah we have fun
with it are you looking forward or a
little bit dreading that your next year
might already be mapped out with Marvel
and then stranger things and that that's
all you're filming
uh yeah next year is going to be very
tough year for me schedule wise we've
already gotten through a lot of that
um I mean the thing that is gratifying
is that it is there are two things that
I love
I love both characters very much
it will be my goodbye to Jim Hopper
though too which is a big deal
um
fortunately I feel like I have a long
time to say goodbye because I think
we're going to take a long time shooting
these episodes I know those tougher
brothers are very
specific and I know they want to get
that last season I mean if you look at
season four I have a feeling that season
five may not be as long
but it certainly will be packed to the
brim with good stuff that you love I
mean they really are getting better
better at giving you
that home run that the the audiences
love and I think that season five will
do that so much so it'll be and I mean
to get to play hopper one last time
will be
really exciting and I'm gonna pour my
soul into it as hard as I can so in that
way scheduling wise it's going to be
crazy you're right I'm just going to be
shooting that but it's been I mean that
role has been the role of a lifetime in
many ways I do I hope
I hope I'll play things further on that
will be even more known in a way I don't
want this to be my my the thing that
people
you know
whatever that means but uh uh well I
know but I know what you mean but I want
to know something is it possible that
you're gonna have to play do
Thunderbolts for two weeks go to
stranger things for a week go back to
Thunderbolts or is it gonna be where
you're just shooting Marvel and then
going to stranger things have you been
talking to my lawyers about what have
you been talking to the first aid
because they're pissed no no because I I
know I know that Thunderbolt starts
filming early next year or sometime next
year and I know that the duffers have
been writing since August because they
told me so I know the scripts are you
know what I mean I know how filmmaking
works
in the room on the deal I need you say
look I know how this works guys this has
already been read no you're right it
really is it's going to have to be a
back and forth with me they're gonna
have to sort of share me uh and so it is
kind of like I don't know exactly how
they're working it but it's a week on
week off two weeks on two weeks of
something like that where I will go back
and forth they both are being shot in
Atlanta so oh that's that's actually
amazing you got so [ __ ] lucky oh my
god well that was yeah that may have
also been structured in a certain way
but yes it is uh it is helpful so I can
just literally you know shoot a scene at
stranger things and get in my car and
run over to the Marvel Studios and shoot
a scene there maybe yeah sure but I do
have you know what I do have real
problems with teams I have facial hair
uh uh conundrums I really have to figure
that out yeah it's a real thing that
that what's really funny is people don't
don't think about that also you might
want to be bigger for Thunderbolts but
you want to be thinner for stranger
things how do you pull that off yeah all
these things you know Prosthetics have
come a long way in so many different
ways so that's wonderful and then it is
another aspect of creative limitation
that you use to your advantages you know
there's great scenes in like Rocky where
like he's up there's no close-up at the
end of the movie it's because they
didn't have enough film stock to shoot
in so it becomes an iconic thing and so
hopefully the idea will be because of
these limitations you have to shoot
these two characters back to back you
use that as inspiration I was like what
can I do that'll be really cool for
Hopper and really cool for Alexi that's
going to be able to do these things in
tandem
um and I'm gonna try to get real create
we're all going to try to get real
creative about it and come up with
something real cool but it definitely is
a factor you don't have just Blank Slate
creativity you have to think
strategically have you actually read the
Thunderbolt script or been told what the
what this is all going to be yes I've
been told what it's all going to be I
have yet to read a script
but I haven't told I've been told the
the ark
uh are you super happy happy or oh my
God this is going to be awesome
it's gonna be really good it's gonna be
really and it's it's not what you expect
it incorporates a couple new elements
new
things that we have yet to see
um
uh in the universe which is really cool
we introduce a thing that's super cool
it's vital
um
I'm psyched at Julia Louis-Dreyfus uh
character is going to be in a bigger way
explored
and I of course you know one of the
things you'll probably know is that the
me and Florence dynamic
will be in there and explore it in a way
that's really cool but
you know all these guys like Sebastian's
character why it's character I just love
this mercenary element in the MCU mcu's
always been sort of elevated in a
certain way Captain America even Iron
Man although he has egos
it's always in it for the right reasons
or ultimately does the right thing and I
like these guys who are a bunch of
losers uh or like a bunch of guys who
can't quite get it right and um
and so far what they've pitched me
just feels really cool
it just feels really cool I mean I wish
I could talk more about it but you know
how it is a year and a half we'll we'll
talk at some junket in 2024. you know
exactly I'll see you then yeah exactly
listen um I I'm I gotta I could keep
talking to you but I gotta rap I'm just
gonna say that you know I'm surprised
that's it we've I I've told you I had
what's wrong
from now on I trust you I am scared but
you were right
I have all these questions here and all
these questions here and none of them
got asked because damn it
at the beginning you're like 20 minutes
I'm like I I needed 30. and I had more
you know um Hey listen man congrats on
everything and uh really have a great
year filming next year and then I didn't
even ask you about Gran Turismo you know
it's uh I will just quickly I will say
it's super fun and that Neil blonde comp
is uh is that even I can't I don't know
that's not how you pronounce it but I
can't so we'll just say Neil
Neil is so cool and such a good director
that I it's really been a joy to work on
this movie and this movie's gonna be
talk about not what you expect with him
at the helm there's a visceralness to
this to this movie into this video game
world that is so cool I can't wait for
you to see this movie yeah yeah it's
also some cool wish fulfillment
and it's a true story you look yeah Sim
racing man who knew these guys are
incredible yeah yeah um Hey listen man
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating thank you for your time and
thanks Matt have a great day